yeah welcome back to the iced coffee
hour
cheers smash the like button away
i'm jack this is marina hey this is our
guest for the 10th ever episode of the
iced coffee hour thank you so much for
tuning in
yeah you picked a good episode to be a
part of today it's a special one
so just to give everyone an overview of
who you are you have
three youtube channels if i'm correct
and between all three channels you have
over four million subscribers right
correct yeah so i started my first
youtube channel
back in 2014 uh when i was trying to get
admitted to
us university and i realized there's not
an information
there's not enough information in
russian um so starting my russian
channel it's over
1 million followers now and i talk about
everything like
life in the u.s investing
started sharing my experience then the
second channel is called lingua marina
this is where i teach people languages
has over 2 million followers and
the latest channel is silicon valley
girl started at two two
years ago to talk about business and
life in silicon valley
it's funny enough that's the channel
that i knew i didn't even know you had
two other channels
yeah i just need silicon it's just so
different yeah that's the thing because
i wanted to target different people
because with lingua marina i realized i
live in the us
but i talk to people from all over the
world but i really want to talk to
people
in the u.s so it had to be a different
channel yeah
but yeah i started watching your channel
about maybe two years ago
because the algorithm the algorithm kept
pushing your stuff
oh nice yeah i love it your videos just
kept coming up recommended
so yeah good good job algorithm oh yeah
thank you
how did you do that did you have like a
marketer or did you just work on the
thumbnails and
study it nothing yeah i just i just
experimented and tried things
and i think whenever you do a video top
10
whatever the algorithm just loves those
videos oh we don't we should do a top 10
podcast now that we've had
10 episodes oh yeah you could do the top
10 iced coffee hours
we could make it 10 hours long that's
smart
so giving a little introduction about
yourself you also have a
course correct yeah i have a
youtube course um actually two youtube
courses how to start on youtube and how
to grow on youtube
but apart from that i think that my most
most of my time goes to my company
called linguatrip it's a silicon valley
startup backed by silicon valley
investors
it's like a study abroad booking
platform for a language travel
and we also have an online part where we
teach people languages online
i didn't know you had another youtube
creator academy because that's what i
have linked down below in the
description so you are you competition
how much you sell it for
uh 199. oh
wow well mine if that with the discount
is 197.
so maybe we just throw in the discount
here the longer kite you let's hear the
link down below
for 197. we'll do it 200 off
there you go i think i have a slightly
different approach i see a lot of
youtubers who are trying to be bilingual
um
enroll my course because they speak two
languages and they want to be
famous and both demographics so yeah
imagine that when when fame is not
enough in one language you're like you
know what how many other languages are
i need to be known in all languages
exactly i got to learn another language
i tried learning spanish
and i had three years of spanish and uh
i don't remember a single thing high
school not a single thing not a single
thing
you speak four languages i speak russian
english german and a little italian
that's impressive this is what you do
when you come from
a foreign country not english-speaking
country because you just have to where
were you born
russia russia and when did you move over
here um 2016.
wow that'll do it yeah because i was
never really forced
to speak another language except in like
a 50-minute class in high school
and that was it yeah you know
did it take you a long time to learn all
those languages or was it kind of just
no yeah i started learning english at
the age of four
and then it was just a long process and
then was german i started at the age of
12
and italian was just for fun it's
impressive
yeah you're never ended with learning a
language you just learn and learn and
learn
wow so how are the the courses going
i've actually stopped
calling them courses i call them
programs now oh because all the amazon
fba people ruined
the word course i think because there's
so many of those courses the first thing
you think course is like ah it's a scam
so i start program yeah that sounds
better yeah i like it so you have a
program you have two programs you sell
yeah and then after that someone's gonna
ruin program and then it's gonna be
something else
so we gotta think we gotta be ahead of
this one and think what's what do we
call it after pro
mentorship everything could just be a
mentorship mentorship is also like this
kind of work it's taught in english for
people who just produce courses and do
nothing
scam artist
a scammer yeah it's a nice word right
yes this is bad not at all yeah because
we have a special word in russia and i i
just
got interviewed by a major russian
magazine on how to tell if a person is a
good course producer or a bad
course producer this is a good spot for
an ad break i think so how
how do you how do you tell um so
basically when somebody produces a
course about a thing he's not an expert
in like for example if you didn't have
any followers on youtube but you started
your pro
program makes sense yeah okay and
we have like i see a lot of people who
are teaching business
but their only business is producing
horses
and teaching other people oh yeah oh
it's it's the people that teach you how
to make money online and they sell of
course
but how they make all their money online
is the course exactly so it's a course
on how to build the course
it's smart yeah it is it works yeah yeah
to to some time as long as it's an
effective course like imagine i go to
you and i'll be like i'm gonna teach you
how you can make a dollar it's only
going to cost one dollar so you pay me a
dollar i'm going to teach you how to
make that dollar back
yeah so to sum it all up essentially
what you are is just an entrepreneur
because you have many different business
ventures what started it all like how
did you
start out what was your first venture uh
linguatrip uh it was it didn't have this
name when we started so we were
both dimitri and i my husband was
studying together in one university
uh we started dating dating data for one
year and then he said
we need to start something together
because you're so good at languages and
there are so many people who want to
travel and learn languages because this
is the reality for europe
and we decided to start our first
company we only had three hundred
dollars
invested three hundred dollars sent our
first client to the uk
and then we only had three clients in a
year but then it just kind of started
growing
and uh yeah it grew too how do you
invest three hundred dollars what do you
what is what is that incorporated
okay made a cpa too so you just got
incorporated and then the rest was just
your time
exactly okay and then what about did you
grow up was it referrals and stuff like
that
we started sending our friends abroad so
the first three clients are our close
friend
and then what did you do before that i
just studied
at a university so i tried working for
avon when i was like 12 i think that was
my first event
cosmetics you're asking the wrong people
about god
yeah cosmetics or macy's it's like
like this pyramid oh i know amway
yeah it's very similar oh okay so it's
it's a multi-level marketing exactly
yeah not pyramid it's multi-level
marketing so you would get it and then
you'd sell it to someone else
and then it trickles down yeah people
can make a lot of money from that if
they if they're at the top of the
pyramid you just always want to be at
the top of the pyramid
you're going to do it you may as well
just do it right have you seen this uh
documentary on netflix
or herbalife john what was it yeah
herbal live oh that's yeah there's some
yeah it's a good i i saw one a while ago
about some clothing company that did
that
where people were spending thousands of
dollars to get started with this
clothing brand
oh my god and they would have these
managers that would just yell at these
people be like you're not selling enough
product
like the only way to move up is you need
like this special thing and this is why
you're not selling enough and they'll
sell you like another two thousand
dollar thing
and it's it's a lot of these like a lot
of people who are like out of work or
whatever just like
going and credit oh oh yeah they were
telling people to open up credit cards
who didn't have the money to pay
for their open up zero percent interest
credit card put it on the credit card
you'll make it all back classic that's
terrible
yeah uh i almost got involved with one
of those before i started working with
you
because i was looking at craigslist ads
for for jobs and because i i just hated
my current my you know my past job so
much i was like what can i do to get out
of here
and i found one it was called cutco and
it was it's the knives
exactly and it was like 20 an hour and i
was like okay this isn't so bad and it
seemed like pretty decent and then i
just i was like okay but there's no way
that they would just accept some random
person you don't need to have any sort
of like
you know history doing something similar
it was just anybody could do it
and i was like this sounds too good to
be true so i just looked up is cutco a
scam
like you know endless results just
saying like yeah i don't trust this
company
that happened to me too in high school i
was 17 and i went
same thing craigslist and i went on
craigslist and there was something about
like you know
being in sales and working your own
hours and being your own boss
and i remember emailing back and forth
with the guy and saying like i just
wanted to learn like i didn't even want
to get paid i just wanted to shadow
this guy and figure out like what he
does all day that's all i wanted
but he ended up meeting me to starbucks
which is the the number one
sign that's probably mlm is they're
meeting you at a starbucks so i actually
wore like a suit oh my god suit to this
thing and this dude was sitting there
with his computer
trying to sell me i kid you not i'm sure
we could look for a screenshot of this
online
uh but it was it was a phone it was like
facetime before there was facetime it
was a phone with the camera on it
and then if someone else had the phone
with the camera on it you guys could see
each other
as you're talking on the phone and it
hooked up to the internet
and anyway i would i would have been
selling those
and that's what it was but he didn't he
had no
intention of like mentoring me or
anything that's what i wanted
but uh yeah i'm sure we could i'm sure
we could find that yeah
my experience was better my mom had to
sign the contract because i was 12.
uh you're 12. yes this is when i started
experimenting wait
wow you were still i was still russia
yeah
in russia at school and i sold
everything to my teachers uh but yeah i
didn't need a lot of money to start up
front
they just gave me the catalogs and i
started that was my first selling
experience
and then um i did some singing for like
five years a song
or something like that um but then yeah
i had some
oh yeah and i had an internship at a
souvenir store where i could practice my
english with um
tourists but then that was it and then
we started a company
wow but working at 12 what prompted you
to
figure i need to make money i just
wanted to try you just want to make my
own
yeah i was dreaming about doing making
money from earlier on
and i was just thinking what can i do at
the age of 12. so you've always had that
mindset like you work hard
yeah exactly smart to market teachers
yeah that's smart because they they you
have a lower likelihood of them saying
no
right right like girl scouts yeah it's
but those are
that's so good yeah and you can't just
say no to like a cute little nose
because you want to encourage that type
of behavior you don't want to be like
no get out get a scam yeah because then
you then you
then they're ruined for the rest so how
many teachers said yes
oh a lot i think that yeah out of you
and then actually making like a deal oh
yeah
well like a hundred dollars was the
maximum that i could make
in a month why was it capped at 100 no
this is
this is what i could do i mean in terms
of like myself
okay um it wasn't a lot of money but
russia was a lot so what would that be
equivalent to in
the us today like a hundred a month
would be a thousand there's a thirty
thousand million
yeah so you barely afford so in russia
we have this different situation like in
the us we pay taxes on
things we own like right property in
russia you don't really pay
if you do pay tax they're really really
small so if you own something
you can just survive on like fifty
dollars or a hundred dollars
because you don't have all the fees so
i'm earning a hundred dollars
at 12 years old it wasn't in russia was
it's got to be thousands basically like
the equivalent well equivalent of a
thousand dollars a month i would say
wow yeah oh my god yeah a 12 if i had
like 50 bucks
whoa i gotta do i gotta just get on a
plane and go to russia
and start doing that wow good gig
impressive geez that is cool so all of
that stuff is what
ultimately led up to you starting your
own business yeah and uh
and it started off slowly for about a
year very slowly for about a year and
then it started accelerating and then
we decided that we don't want to have
this offline business we want to build
an online platform
and uh dmitry my husband had this idea
of you know
raising money in silicon valley and i
was like why would people
in silicon valley give us money because
we're a no-name
company in russia but we just started
reaching out to people and then we had a
meeting with a guy who was forbes 30
under 30. saw this company here in the
us and he was traveling
around europe to just meet startups and
we had a meeting and he was like wow i'm
going to introduce you to
y combinator and 500 startups top two
accelerators
um here and he introduced us and the
next night i had an interview
and then i think it was tuesday morning
i wake up and
you should understand our situation
we're running out of money we had a lot
of debts
we didn't know how to market the product
and then one morning i wake up and i see
this email from 500 startups
we're offering you a hundred thousand
dollars in investment
wow it's a four-month program so we just
backed and
um came here that's incredible what did
it take for you to be able to
get the investors to like invest in you
like
a lot of meetings a lot of knows i
remember uh being on a stage in russia
in front of russian investors and
pitching my startup and then the guy
who's considered like a really good
investor in russia he stands up and says
the best thing you can do right now is
shut down your company because we've
already worked with a similar company
and they couldn't make any profit
so i think you know you just need to
find a job or do something
else and i was there like standing on
the stage nearly crying because you know
the pressure and a
[ __ ] yeah yeah exactly
yeah that was kevin o'leary who said
that
yeah and then for that reason i'm
barbara
yeah and then you know just a lot of
bitching a lot of meetings
that's horrifying yeah but props to you
thank you and then because of that you
decided to start
uh your youtube channel yeah so two
factors first i was preparing for gmat
and i realized all the info is in
english and i wanted to start a russian
channel and then we moved to the us
and uh we got a retired police
interceptor for 2700 on craigslist
that's cool because this is like a car
we could afford and that looked
decent and i made a video about that and
it went
viral in russia because you know a girl
driving a police car
yeah in america and then i realized
youtube is something
six months after starting a youtube
channel i got my first hundred dollars
and i was like wow
that's kind of cool yeah yeah that first
little bit that you make from youtube is
the most exciting money anybody's ever
going to make
really it's it's like getting introduced
to like a drug i
i don't i don't do drugs let's make it
clear i'm imagining that's
what doesn't do drugs or but like i
would imagine like people say like they
get hooked on
yeah like i remember even earning like
10 cents on youtube this beginning few
days it's so it was so cool for me i was
like oh wow how do i get more of this
how big was your first check uh it was
no checks it's direct deposit i think
the minimum is a hundred so
um yeah i mean i don't know probably a
few hundred bucks for that first
it was like i don't know the first the
first actual month of being monetized i
think i made like 1100
or something like that for that first
full month yeah that's pretty cool
though yeah
how about you a hundred because that was
like accumulated
for a couple months oh right i didn't
even withdraw that so it took a while
yeah
wow that was pretty fast yeah it was
beautiful and have you found
that youtube is better to use as a way
to get more people to go to your
business or
it's good in itself with like adsense
and stuff like that so first it was the
way to get more customers for a lingua
trip
and then i think when i started a
channel in english this is when i
started seeing good adsense revenue
because if you're
blogging in russian you don't get a lot
of i think the cpm in russian is
so much two dollars it seems like almost
every other country
is just a fraction at least right now
what the united states is but i think
give it like a few years other countries
are going to start ramping because i
don't think they're
are they catching on to youtube do they
do they know about it are there enough
advertisers
it's just people earn less money in
those countries
okay they have a lot of advertisers
matches just how much they can pay per
click
i guess uh that makes sense yeah now we
have a very monetizable audience your
view right now you watch it
you have a valuable view your view is
probably worth
two cents believe it or not so thank you
really thank you do you get a lot of
views from uh countries like india
not so much i think for us it's about 65
united states and then canada
and then there's so much australia a lot
of
australia and then some of you a uk
it's a big one and then it just it goes
down from there it's like
it's really good norway's like even
higher than the us i think it's
2x compared to the us i guess we know
what we're going to be doing
exactly so you found it was best to to
use it in the beginning to market
to yeah get a better audience yeah and
then i started vlogging in english and i
realized this is a completely different
check that's coming in every month yeah
how many streams of income
do you have if you're willing to
disclose this oh sure so
language have number one uh google
adsense number two
paid partnerships affiliate programs um
my youtube course investment income oh
investment income just edit that
oh instagram ads when people buy ads for
me on
instagram oh yeah that's familiar how
does that work oh
like sponsored like sponsorships oh i'm
like wait instagram has ads
what yeah sponsorships um
oh and i have my workbooks this is an
amazing
income source because you produce it's
like a books like a pdf
i call them handbooks and workbooks and
they sell for like seven dollars
and the one that i made was for english
language learners it has
180 pages and in the first month we made
25 000
selling it um wait what is it exactly
it's like you know it's a lot of things
in one handbook so we have like a
thousand words that every english
language learner should know
tv shows that you should watch like a
lot of information about the english
language youtube channels you should
watch
uh the iced coffee hour graham stefan
exactly oh and imagine imagine if if
people
could sponsor themselves in there sort
of like the best tv shows and it's like
it's all paid getting there best
youtuber the bet the best programs to
buy
best coffee to drink that's smart so you
have this like
book the workbook and that's another
form of income yeah so you have like
seven or so
yeah quite a few yeah are you able to
disclose percentages or
numbers or no we want to know number i
mean number is ideal
we don't we don't have to okay so yeah
sure i think uh
google adsense this month is around 17
000. for which for all combined okay
compared to you
yeah i wish you yesterday oh wait which
one the uh the
net worth oh wow yeah yeah yeah a lot of
people watch that
yeah um then
so workbooks around 10k every month
uh paid partnerships uh 30k
a month wow wait what what kind of paid
partnerships do you do
so like companies that we work with like
product placements in my videos what
companies
audible skillshare uh
we got it we got to talk about this
afterwards because yeah i'm not doing
anywhere close to that wow maybe i'm
getting yeah
really who are you working with all of
them uh
what are you talking about for a sponsor
yeah like
you mentioned a sponsored chat well not
all of them uh let's see which one is it
audible skillshare uh blinkist
no i i i just did morning brew which is
an online newsletter
investment newsletter which seems like a
really cool company um
trade coffee which has been awesome i
like them a lot
uh can you just close how much you
charge i can't not on the pod
i'll disclose that separately but i said
i'll just cut it out it'll bleep it out
yeah is that i mean is that about on
average really but you just do more
uh yeah and my channel's a lot smaller
but that's the thing that's
oh yeah you should have charged a lot
more be confident oh yeah and then
they'll be like wow
people like you charge like are you
serious
just bleep out the numbers like for this
part like the
part just bleep those out i mean i do i
do yeah i mean yeah
i'm getting shortchanged i mean person
maybe because i hired a salesperson and
she was able
to secure all the deals
people reach out to us all the time and
they're from agencies that link people
agencies are not good because agencies
are going to take
part of your profit fair enough so if
you have a sales person who's reaching
out to companies that you like
um so we have this strategy where um you
know crunchbase
is a website that says how much the
company has raised so if i tell
kate for example i want to advertise
somebody in education
she goes to crunch base sees who
recently raised series or series b
that means they have a lot of marketing
budget she reaches out to them
says hey we have this amazing channel do
you want to collaborate and if they have
an ongoing program
sometimes they reach out themselves but
there's also i'd be interested
and let me know on that i'm see
this is it you're getting a real
conversation i mean that's the thing
like we would be
grounded in two years my net worth
do you know what we need wow honey to
sponsor us
oh honey honey i think honey may be an
offer
but uh believe it or not i wanted like i
wanted more for them and they were
gr i love it but they're they did they
barely offered they were paying less
than almost anybody else
but like h3 and huge youtubers do honey
and i feel like they probably get like
a lot i think honey is such a good app
and they're so safe that anybody would
just
their audience wouldn't be upset because
like sponsors are one of those things at
least on my channel where i'm afraid if
i do it too often
then it just kind of ruins the message
so you gotta sprinkle it in every now
and there's
that trade-off but honey i feel like if
i mention honey to my audience you'd be
like oh
thank you so much graham thank you for
mentioning honey
and they're not going to be upset versus
maybe somebody else
yeah so wow i'm learning a lot
yeah okay find something new yeah so we
got to do that
sponsorships um yes some of them are on
instagram but youtube is a
bigger chunk um workbooks um
last month it was around 9k what else
well language of salary i don't want to
disclose it
what else do we have oh courses last
month i made
around 30k on courses
that's good that's really good what have
we averaged this month like 50
60 yeah maybe around there a month i
think you do a little bit less than that
a little less than that a little bit
well it's it's it's staggered because
everyone waits until i have a sale
and then and then it goes down the
average yeah yeah because i only really
will do
like a like a sale push like maybe twice
a year mm-hmm uh do you do any
marketing no oh that's the thing so if
people want to buy one of my
programs programs in the description
i never really market i never push it so
it's there if people want to get it
and if they don't want to get it that's
fine too so i never i never push it
because we have
marketing okay marketing okay webinars
and stuff
oh yeah so i've never done that it's
just the occasional
just link in the video swipe up story
and that's it
so i purposely tried to not push it
because i feel like
i don't want to be too pushy
gosh i'm under charging on on
sponsorship anyway that's going to
ruin my i'm going to be up if you know
you know that meme
where the the the girlfriend is uh what
was it
oh what's that what's he thinking yeah
what's he thinking and he's like he
looks all concerned that's gonna be me
tonight yeah like three o'clock in the
morning
how much do they leave on the table for
sponsorships
wow so i i was adding it up in my head
it's almost a hundred thousand a month
it is about yeah about wow so that's
there's your title right there yeah so
let's talk about being a business owner
how is your time allocated throughout
your average day
and what's it like to just be a business
owner yeah that's a great question um so
i start working in the morning around 8
a.m whenever
my baby wakes up so um from 9am
to 10am i think it's just back and forth
with uh with the team then uh
light lunch breakfast time with my baby
then she goes to sleep and i film my
videos
and she wakes up then maybe so it's you
know back and forth sometimes i have
days when i just film so today
uh all that came over my camera guy and
we just filmed the whole day because i'm
leaving tomorrow
and i need a lot of content before i go
uh but i would say
per day i spend like a couple of hours
on my companies in a couple of hours on
creating content
so four days i try to you know work for
four days uh four hours a day
yeah i was having a child in the middle
of all that congratulations
thank you yeah she's that oh my goodness
yeah she's eight months old uh yeah it's
it's pretty cool i have my mom here she
came over from russia to help out
because otherwise i don't know how are
you going back to russia
uh so we're going there for a couple
months and then we're going to come back
probably with a nanny because my mom
can't be here for
so long is that where you live i used to
live there
yeah but you currently like you're oh so
i've lived in san francisco since 2016.
um
and then we just got tired of the city
because we lived in one of the high
rises
and then the lockdown started and you
know going down an elevator with like 10
people
and uh every every walk was a struggle
and we don't have a lot of parks and the
city everything is closed and you can't
really use the city's benefits
and we decided to move out and we moved
out in may and we just traveled
throughout california we've been to
dillon beach malibu malibu is our
favorite location
so far um palo alto
with a baby with a baby wow and that was
the perfect time i feel the travel
oh yeah exactly kind of with everything
shut down so many deals the first trip
that we took was in may and we stayed at
this airbnb in malibu for
200 a night now it's renting out for
1 600 a night because they just realized
people started traveling so we got
a lot of great deals in maine june now
it's not that well i was thinking for
traffic
like almost anywhere you drive right
because that's the first thing from l.a
it's like
what's the traffic light yeah traffic
there's no traffic right now which is
which is a benefit
yeah and not a lot of tourists which is
great yeah on being a business owner how
many
employees do you have so we um we have a
lot of contractors this is the way we
structure the company because there are
a lot of things
people can do from all over the world
and we have a team in several countries
we have 55 people on the team we used to
have 80
but then uh with the illness
the illness you know we just say the
illness yeah because you don't get
demonetized you no longer get
no yeah i heard it was no longer i don't
believe it really
i don't think okay i don't know just in
case okay just the illness let's talk
about
spending money what percent of your
income do you save
so last month's month was it was a bad
month because i spent 50
of my income that's a lot of money
that's a lot truck because we're
traveling
we're traveling i got flights to russia
i got you know just thing oh that
includes my team my personal team
that includes my personal assistant
salesperson
marketing person so i i still consider
it my personal income so
uh that's why but yeah normally i try to
spend
20 to 30 percent of my income that's
that's that's good
yeah that's good but you spend one less
than one percent something like that i
mean it's absurdly though well now i got
the house
so it's it's a little bit more but the
net the net
you know i do some creative numbers
there to make it lower
counting the rent to my other place but
anyway yeah it's something like that
yeah and what do you think about living
frugally
i don't like it oh get out
you know what i know what i started
doing this month whenever i buy
something from a company that means i
trust this company so for example when i
got my first iphone if i
bought apple stocks as well i would have
afforded like three
iphones with one stock today so this is
what i thought if i trust a company if i
like it
if i make a purchase uh then i would
invest the same amount of money into
stocks because if i believe in it it
will probably grow so
i'm trying to follow this rule this
month we'll see it's a good way of
thinking
yeah but yeah i i don't like to live
really because i think i'm missing out
on things like
travel i love traveling and i just can't
and
when you have a family like i have my
mom and my daughter travel with me and i
need
you know a nice house because we need
space and film there
that costs money uh i want a nicer car
because i like
get a tesla travel do you drive a nice
car we ordered cyber truck
i have unfortunately whenever that
happens yeah porsche
which one uh okay km oh the suv
yeah yeah okay i forgot what i was about
to say
i was about to say something and i was
like this is a group you know i
watched some of your videos about living
for gillian they're like
should i try it and then like that nah
it's just like saving you're pretty
good yeah i'm trying but i really
because i feel
people have created so many things i
want to try like different hotels i want
to stay in or
you know jewelry that is nice or cars
that are piece
pieces of art um i just want to test it
out because there is one life you know
yeah
i mean there's ways to get the same
experiences for the less that's right
like like your porsche
by the same car a few years old
yeah exactly travel you could you could
just do credit card churning
it's credit card sign up bonuses a lot
of ways to get the same experience like
like food
go to the happy hour stuff like that
that's easy i think it all
just comes down to what you really want
out of life and if you
because as long as you're not stupid
with it because obviously you aren't
because you're still saving a
decent amount of money and if you just
want you know
to spend that extra 15 or whatever
yeah and the mindset also because uh
when i was
at the university i spent a lot of my
mental energy on
how do i save money how do i have lunch
for you know
uh the light do we need to fix it no oh
oh it's not plugged in all the way
oh it must have come undone it's our
rinky dink
studio
yeah everything in the bottom wasn't
plugged in all the way it just came out
yes got the electric in this place it's
going and it's gonna blow in a moment
oh my gosh yes at some point i realized
i spent too much of my mental energy on
figuring out
how i saved money yeah and then i
thought okay if i
end up spending 15 more 20
more um i just saved that mental energy
that and invested into something like
business
or another youtube video yeah and uh
this is why i stopped doing like
you know calculations all the time like
oh my god i need to shop here
because it's cheaper i find it fun
though that that to me is a bit it's
just
like a sport you know it's like oh it's
like two dollars
i i got him i won yes i won this time
yeah
yeah i i see where you're coming from
and i've always kind of thought that in
the back of my head with graham
because you and i have spent a crazy
amount of time sometimes just doing
stupid things like when we were
like trying to put in that light in the
guest unit like how long did we spend on
that an
hour yeah at least like we put in a
light right
it's like your timers were so much more
than that and that was a stress remember
how frustrated we were i got angry
standing on like the piano those are
memories those are memories that you
remember
that's true yeah same with this i
installed this this is like i installed
myself
i think that the guy wanted like 80
bucks to install this
uh we did it in like an hour
only 90 minutes whenever i look at it
every every morning
every night i get home it's like you
look at the light you're like i did that
yeah as long as you don't get frustrated
because i get frustrated if i have to
clean the whole house and i realize i
could have paid somebody to do that
and could have you know spend time with
my child instead i just get frustrated
yeah what might be different if you have
a family yeah you know that's true
like like a kid and then but but then
but then
you could teach your child how to do
stuff like that
you know she does all the stuff yeah old
enough to like wire
something together with electricity and
at four or five whatever
and then they can you could get them to
pay for themselves it's a marketable
trait and then you could then you could
figure out some infinite monetization
loop where you react to them reacting to
sesame street or something like that
some weird stuff and uh yeah you're good
yeah market your children that's always
a great
thing to do but yeah i mean we've
strung up the lights in the backyard i
mean that took like two and a half hours
yeah
two and a half hours me and graham so
five hours between our time
stringing up lights in the backyard
using like a broom
and like literally tying the extension
cord to a rock and trying to throw it
over it yeah there's a tree out in the
back that's like
30 feet tall and we wanted to get these
cool like edison lights around the tree
that was 30 feet tall we had no way of
getting up there jack tried to climb the
tree
that didn't work we didn't have a ladder
we couldn't hire a professional but
i wanted it done that night so yeah we
got creative two and a half hours later
we just stung the light around i mean
it's perfect yeah
so oh by the way if i mean if anyone
needs lights strung up
you know in l.a area we're a good duo
we'll take hours yeah installing those
lights but we'll do it we'll get it
right
we'll have the good memories yeah that
was a fun night though i think we got
uh did we get sushi that night i think
we rewarded ourselves
i think so no you see that our thing is
that if we get
the agreement was that if we post a
video and that video is a one out of ten
meaning it's the best performing video
out of the last ten we get sushi and
that's our celebration to get a one out
of ten so i think that day we got a one
out of ten
and then we installed the lights here
yeah nice we do reward ourselves yeah on
occasion
but that's good that yeah you know you
you found your balance and i think it's
totally somewhere
like reasonable so yeah but i still feel
that i have to make more money
in order not to end up spending 50 of my
income
and uh what are some of the things that
you've spent money on that you think
graham would just
like disagree with to afford the car
not necessarily because porsches have
good resale value
uh i mean what did you buy it for 50k
50 games how long have you had it for uh
a year and a half what year is it 2016.
i think
it's probably worth 35 40. that's not
terrible
yeah it's pretty much the same
calculator pretty much the same as uh
leasing
but you're releasing a new one but i
don't really like the new one because i
like the older one with all the buttons
leasing could be better for you as a
write-off though oh yeah
that's true but that car i think would
be better as a writer nothing about
write-offs when i started
when i when i bought the car i mean it's
good you own it now but in the future
for
i would probably lease a car like that
is it better he's a tesla are you
leasing a tesla
it's terrible terrible uh lease rates on
teslas
but are you leasing or 78 dollars a
month 78 dollars a month so
yeah it was worth it to buy it yeah you
didn't see that video that's 78 dollars
it's one of your best performing videos
yeah it was yeah
i didn't see it yeah no tesla offers so
many rebates we should put a referral
link
for the tesla in the district let's
actually do this uh but they have so
many rebates available and at the time i
think there was a 3750 dollar
federal tax credit there was a
california
tax credit on top of that uh there was
i was able to depreciate the car there's
so many things with tesla
that just it made so much sense to get
the car into the first year it only cost
me 78
a month and then after that i mean it
was really just the cost of insurance
which was nothing anyway
and um there's no gas electricity was a
dollar a day so it just was so cheap it
was cheaper than any other car i can get
nice so alongside the porsche is there
anything else that you think
um that's not that bad flying business
class
you would just hit pro is business never
done something at first
uh on some flights yes and sometimes no
uh but yeah when you fly for 13 hours
i flew economy a lot of times and you
just come
to a place where you're traveling
completely you know sleepless and you're
jet lagged
and then we started flying business and
it's a completely different experience
because you can you know sleep when you
fly and then you come rested
yeah i've never flown for more than like
five hours six hours the most
have you ever flown business or first no
you haven't no
even with the miles that you're getting
i don't know i i i'm in a terrible habit
of saving
my miles at this point for i don't know
what uh you're just avoiding so many
months
i want to get a million miles don't you
want to try that yes lifestyle for once
i'm curious but part of me part of me is
afraid of uh liking it too much and then
but i also don't want to waste all my
miles income yeah but i look at the
miles and i'm like i could get x amount
of flights with those miles or i can get
like
three big flights i'd rather a whole
bunch of little tiny ones
i don't know i'm sure i'm sure i'll take
a hundred hundred bucks
yeah i mean i'll do it at some point big
ones are like 3k or 4k
and then you're just saving i'll do it
at some point macy and i wanted for my
birthday and obviously this didn't
happen because of the illness that went
around but we were going to be going
through there's a place she tagged me on
instagram
as a joke uh called graham's place
and we clicked it because it was
actually a thing and clicked it it's an
island it's called graham's place and
it's just
i don't it's somewhere off of um is it
off of mexico or something
so anyway it's it's it's somewhere it's
like seven hours away but our plan was
to go to graham's place
for my birthday and yeah i would have
used my miles on that
i don't know if i would have gone like
business class but
maybe i don't know yeah i've always
wondered what that would be like too
but there's no way i would ever just
such a completely different experience
when you don't have to wait in line when
you get into the airplane that's true
waiting in line so you don't have to and
you get a business lounge where you can
take a shower
oh but you but you have a priority if
you have priority pass that does that
though ah not really
because uh for example sfo san francisco
airport you have this pretty bus
lounge which is not a lounge at all it's
just an area where you rest but then you
have the united lounge that you can use
if you're flying business
and it's uh i have united lounge access
too oh you do yeah oh
credit card credit card jpmorgan reserve
oh
of course that's good yeah i like united
and then i have the
centurion lounge oh nice okay then you
have
covered yeah yeah yeah and then maybe
the last one would be like staying
in five-star hotels like four seasons
because i just like these
yeah i stayed at the win the other week
um
for fourth of july that was a that was a
cool one that was one of the first
like that was probably the nicest hotel
i've stayed at was it worth it
probably not i mean it was it was nice
but i'm not sure it was like nice night
i don't know i i just i don't
i'm not a huge fan of hotels i just like
having my own space like an airbnb
i think would be a much better value
than a hotel plus it's like i hate
having you park your car in a parking
structure
and it takes you 10 minutes to walk
through the hotel like up to your room
and i just i don't like it i like the
park
walk through door and then i'm there
it's nice but it just
yeah let's talk about investments so
what's your investment portfolio look
like do you manage it yourself or do you
have an advisor
yeah i manage it myself and that was by
the way one of my questions
so basically i have i don't have a lot
investor right now because i'm still
like
maybe i should still have it on my la
bank account or
capital one savings account uh but i've
invested in some
uh index funds with vanguard um i think
i have this
uh the one that's mimicking five hundred
the one
x yeah and then international avtix
i think and then the one that has bonds
and
blacks or whatever it is and
uh oh the one that's um mimicking
properties so it's like a
that's like a reit okay all right and
then i have some stocks um
and so my goal is to have 2.5 million
invested in five years okay
and um so i'm thinking whether we should
get something like a property
but the the thing here is that i don't
want to get something just for
renting it out i want to get something
that i would be comfortable living in
with a family
that's good school safe neighborhood and
also a place where i can network so
something like well silicon valley is
impossible with
this kind of money like malibu for
example i really like the neighborhood
close to l.a
and then it's very quiet um
so yeah but on the other hand you know
you have those properties that you can
buy for like 250k or
400k 500k but i won't live there
so there's this trade of whether i
should get investment property or
something where i can live but that will
be
more expensive maybe not a good deal i
don't think investment property is worth
your time i mean if you're making that
amount of money
you going and researching properties and
trying to like navigate a mortgage
on those things and then renting it out
and dealing with a property manager
probably isn't
worth it unless you get such a good deal
where it's like you can't pass it up and
there's so much equity in the property
that you just basically walk into but
you doing all the legwork
yourself at this i just don't think it's
worth it why why are you doing it
because i've already done it yeah well
two things one is because i mean that's
just
what i've known my entire life is just
real estate real estate investing
uh but even now i don't look at it the
same way
uh because a lot of that a lot of the
legwork i did when like
that was really worth my time like
really going in there and making like 80
grand in equity i would do any like i
managed all this project myself i was
there every single morning just like
figuring out contractors
and it's just not worth my time anymore
to do that because you're still buying
you bought something this one yeah so i
bought this i mean this was this was
more so for myself but i also i liked it
long term as an investment
but um but yeah and we needed the space
here but uh
yeah i mean right now i'm looking for
something else maybe as
like an office space that i can get
nearby here and then renovate and
but but that's more so just mostly for
yourself not
notice right well well the office would
be more for tax reasons
but um yeah for me going and trying to
get a property and renovate it it's like
i wouldn't do it i wouldn't do it right
now at least at least for me at this
time
okay got it yeah i think for you at your
level it's just
stick with something basically you don't
even have to think about unless it's
such a good deal where it's
it makes sense and then obviously if you
get something for yourself
there's a price you'll pay for that
obviously so who knows if that'll be a
good investment long term but i think if
you get something for yourself as long
as you plan to live there for longer
than like 10 15 years
it's going to be way cheaper to buy
something yeah that's that's also the
thing we travel all the time
one day we want to live in palo alto the
next day we like san francisco
so we're all over the place it's
probably better and until you're looking
for a place to really settle down for
like 15 years it's probably
better for you to rent and then you have
the mobility to get up and move around
as you please
yeah not pay all the taxes right yeah on
average how many hours do you think you
work per week and what do you do to
unwind and de-stress so in total
i say i work four hours every day i
don't really have a weekend because
on the weekend i post on instagram and i
think about content for the next week so
i try to have one day off that's hard um
to relax good question i watch other
people's videos
i read books i take courses take
my programs buy programs and watch
courses watch programs
um yeah shop sometimes
that's family that's not de-stressing
that's stressful for me yeah
i bought a bean bag today by the way did
you really actually soak
it like a big one or like yeah a six
foot bean bag
yeah i'm dead serious wow yeah
that's a good boost yeah bean bags are
really good that's what i thought
because i wanted to be
like sometimes i see these chairs and
like everything is so neatly like place
i want to think did you just kind of
like toss down like i could work from
there it's comfortable or i could work
from over there i can move it around
so yeah i bought a beanbag but i price
shopped on amazon uh there was a beanbag
for like 250 bucks
and then i found the same bean bag on
wayfair for like
one 155 so i saved a hundred dollars
versus search what's up reverse images
classic
nice nice that's a good purchase right
now actually it might be bigger than six
feet because they ordered the xxl they
had an xl and then i ordered the xxx
you're gonna be loving it yeah i think
so i'm excited
oh it comes on friday the 31st nice yeah
so that's my splurge like that's what i
like splurged on today was i bought a
bean bag
that's cool yeah that's cool yeah i
tried doing that doesn't work for me
no bean bags why no i mean when you call
150 purchases that's a big deal yeah
that's a big deal for me i thought you
meant a bean bag like i tried the bean
bag didn't work
i'm like what could that not be for
cause i i've
i've actually never had a bean bag
before ever like my friends have had
bean bags growing up
yeah it's so cool just to jump in them
um they're the best i've never had one
so now i get down yeah all right so
what i found really interesting is a
trend i've noticed
is that people that are very successful
like you and graham in your free time to
de-stress and unwind
you do things that are productive and
something that will like
take you further in life like because i
feel i feel bad whenever i
don't do something that's productive
yeah i i have hard
hard time actually having rest and i
think that comes from my childhood
whenever
it was weekend i wasn't allowed to go to
parties i wasn't allowed to do
bad stuff by my parents so i just had to
stay at home and work
and if i didn't work i felt like i'm
missing out on something so
i always need to do something otherwise
i feel bad yeah
yeah i'm the same way yeah for me the
drums is a good way to
de-stress really like towards yeah yeah
exactly and you see the progress towards
something like that same with gym
tick-tock is a good way to de-stress i
started doing videos for tick-tock and
it's a lot of fun when you try and
dance and graham you got to start that i
thought oh
i thought about doing it today believe
it or not it's not too late
i don't know i got i got caught up in
something else but
i'll do a tick-tock that's good yeah
that's good moving in the right
direction but yeah i think that's great
because that's something i've been
personally trying to work on is in my
free time
i'm always trying to find enjoyment out
of things that'll be more productive in
my life
this guy wanted to be on the channel
i've seen him before yeah wait really
yeah
he's trending yeah
yeah this guy he reached out
wow he's got 13.6 million followers now
back when i looked at him he had maybe
like a million two million
and that was just a few months ago yeah
you grow really fast
wow have you have how's your growth been
oh almost a million we forgot to mention
that you're almost at a millionaire
i feel like i'm missing on it so
seriously between like
there's so many things now that i'm and
also for
tick-tock there's a cool strategy
because you can repurpose the content
you already have for
youtube i was telling graham what he
should do is do
like post a video and then the top
comment on that video
you know the top finance question
comment he'll just make a video the next
time
the next one and it's super easy content
because he already has exactly what he's
gonna do
in the top comment what's your what's
your tick tock lingua marina
t learn english oh so it's more language
stuff
yeah so basically what i do i haven't
produced any single video for this tick
tock wow
um my team so i have an sms
listen up okay and a videographer so
they just take my videos
they added them so it so they fit
textual format and they just post them
themselves
so i haven't done anything for that it
just grew
all right it's smart it's good to have a
team
do you have any sponsorships or anything
for your tick tock or not yet
so far is it not yet profitable um i
think they they've introduced
monetization recently
so you can go live and people can donate
yeah and this is the way to monetize but
i haven't
got any any money out of it yet but
people
start so the company started asking how
much the
product placement would be on tiktok
i gotta do it you gotta do it dude how
did you get verified on tick tock
um i i have a manager that's fixed you
have a tick tock manager
yeah how did they how did that how do
they reach out they just reached out
yeah they reached out on instagram i
think and they said we saw you started
on tiktok oh no they actually reached
out on tick tock no
they sent me a message on tick tock when
i started and i think they're just
tracking people who have
um followers on other platforms yeah and
they reach out and
help it's given me so much to think
about now i've resisted
for months did you just i know me too me
too i remember gary vee started talking
about it like
a year and a half ago and i was like you
gotta listen to gary vee on this side
i know it's not too late well until it
gets banned it's not gonna get banned
but
what are your plans for the future and
how do you make sure that
every day you're growing and moving in
the right direction
that's a good one um so my plans want
financial goals
invest 2.5 million and have 2.5 million
invested in five years
um start a lot of companies like try out
new things because i feel that we've
been working on linguatrip for
um what is it five years and uh i feel
that we have an amazing team to
try new things within the company and
also outside the company
so just launching new companies and tech
companies
growing my personal brand who do you
aspire to be
really i like my current really yeah
you're
currently you're my favorite youtuber
and so the thing with me like with
following people
i follow somebody i try to learn as much
as i can try to copy as much as i can
and then i move on to the next person
and this is the way i learn about things
i'm learning
about investment investing right now i'm
learning i thought that was a joke at
first i'm like oh
no seriously no this is this is the way
it does so before that
it was like garyvee i learned a lot
about social media started tick tock
listened to his castle understood that
it's not for me i can't do
what he does like wake up every morning
hustle and hustle um and so yeah it's
like i have probably two people per year
that i try to study
uh yeah and this is the way it's an
honor wow that's so cool thank you yeah
thank you
yeah but it goes like i'm learning from
you today like there's there's things
that i'm thinking like
there's like three good things today
yeah that uh extract from this i'm gonna
be up late tonight i'm just gonna be
thinking
geez when did you first find out about
graham
or what video i think it was uh december
last year
and i think it was something about
investing
uh and i just started watching and
december
oh so that would have been about 18
months ago oh no so the first video that
oh okay i remember it so your interview
with a tech lead
because he's from silicon valley you
found that video so yeah i saw you
i heard about your income on youtube and
i was like wow
that's crazy and then i watched your
video about your monthly income
breakdown and then they just started
consuming
because see those are the things that uh
uh
that i really believe that that's what
gets people in or some of those like the
surface level here's my income breakdown
and then it gets people into investing
it's just the bait i don't wanna say
it's never like a bait and switch but
it's like debate that gets you
interested in so like for a lot of these
kids
they have no desire to learn business or
invest until they see a lamborghini
and they're like oh i want the
lamborghini how do i get there oh no i
gotta i gotta
work hard invest and save my money but
but it gets them through the door
so that's what a lot of those income
videos do they they do the best yeah and
i think
it's important to be open about your
income because for many people it's like
a taboo topic you ask them
i don't feel comfortable but when you're
open people just realize that they can
do that as well
because they you show them the path yeah
and that's super important yeah that's
very true i wish more people were open
about their income
me too uh because i i was half expecting
you to say like no we can't go over like
numbers but what but we'll go over
percentages
so i was really happy to hear you go
over now because then it's like
we learn things about like our sponsors
exactly i'm messing up there
so i wonder i wonder what we could have
learned from those percentages that they
just don't
i'll tell you did you always expect to
be
in some sort of work line like this or
no
oh no when i was like 16 or 17
my dream was to move to florida and
start a bakery
that was like my top dream but then i
met my husband and
things changed what would you bake
cupcakes really yeah oh wow should have
brought some cupcakes do you do baked
cupcakes now
i used to use them okay you can open up
a cupcake business oh you make a program
on how to bake cupcakes wow i bet if you
did i seriously i bet if you spent like
a day making a whole how-to tutorial
about how to bake cupcakes
one of my friends does it you know the
thing on uh in russia with instagram
like
everyone who has over 10 000 followers
has a program these days
because this is one of the fastest ways
to make money and that's the thing i can
find a program when is it going to burn
out it used to be ebooks
that used to be the thing in like the
the mid 2000s early 2000s it was always
ebooks and people would make these
ebooks and sell for like 20 30
and then now it's video courses so i'm
curious what it's going to be i don't
see a lot of like people
in the us like american bloggers do that
i see that
everywhere in russia or like eastern
europe but not here
i bet they're all just giving money to
each other though you know like jack
will have a course
100 bucks i give jack 100 but he'll buy
my course so so we're really just
giving it to you so that's zero to
everybody but it's like so i give out a
hundred dollars but i'm receiving
it's just a constant flow yeah do you
have any advice for
graham or i uh
i think you should enjoy life a little
more oh i do enjoy i do
i do yeah the things that people have
created enjoy places in the world travel
more
because you have the resources and i
just think there's this part of your
life that you haven't
discovered yet yeah like traveling and
stuff i'm open to doing it but i will
find a way to monetize that i mean
that's that's the thing so
you can first of all if you're doing
something in that location you can ride
off part of your truck
right yeah um then you can have hotels
uh provide you free accommodation that's
what i do a lot of times
okay then you can review business class
flights and you get uh good revenue from
that there are many ways
to monetize how about advice for jack oh
curious here's the thing everyone that's
on the phone
jack has one year left of college but
right he's been doing this kind of like
full time kind of like as a cool test
the last few months
um i wanted to just go full time and
just
skip out of last year of college
studying economics
what do you think oh still get a
bachelor's just in case
just in case just in case what yeah
[Music]
but for what you do did you need a
college degree
not really but i needed my network
but but what about this network here we
got the same access to you without
college degrees
and your network different it's a
different kind of network
i don't academia i don't know it's a
hierarchy
like we don't belong to that upper what
do you mean because we don't have a
bachelor's
nobody asks it's not about that i just
think you know
it's it's another step that you can take
it's it's an easy step
one year it's not like four years and
then you have these opportunities i
don't know but i'm telling you he could
he could take a year off
do it full-time and then decide then if
you want to go because i just wanted to
stay and when i got yes that's what it's
about
obviously like i think it's such a funny
thing to think of like graham and i
showing up at like thing or like some
like event or something
and like some people are looking at us
from a file oh yeah those are the two
guys that didn't go to college
but at least like if i went to college
it would be like one of us
no i think it's uh people actually now
in my opinion prefer it
it's it's taken as a thing like they
didn't finish college because
they were that good they didn't have to
it's like the dude walking into a high
end like luxury boutique
wearing sweatpants that's the dude with
money because he doesn't have to dress
up for anybody
yeah i mean i like that thing yeah i
like that the status thing now not to go
to school
that's the way i see it but you can take
the advantage of current situation to
study online
that's can you take
because i have upper divs is like what i
really have left and
you can't really do that online we
should just leave it to the people in
comments like just comment below
i think the pieces you guys should
decide but the thing is
my backup plan would be to be a real
estate appraiser
which i does not require a college
degree either
but my backup backup plan i have one
mcdonald's i i've never said this but
i've always kind of thought it is to be
a teacher
which is really funny because my mom's a
teacher and my dad is a real estate
appraiser
so i but like i would like to be a
teacher if possible as a backup backup
plan
online teacher you need to have i
wouldn't want to do that i like the
chatting and the socializing teach
everyone here i
guarantee everyone here would would pay
for your class
oh man well i was still doing it right
i forgot it's uh it's opposite day today
so whatever you say
jack has to do the opposite of it so
that makes sense
yeah yeah all right but
finally for the last thing is graham and
i
want a little bit of a lesson in a
different language
oh you know um when i posted this story
on
um on my instagram asking people to ask
you questions i have some followers
who are russian who live in the us and
there is a way to call you in russian
which is like
a nice way
say hi to graham
how do you say smash the like button um
smash is it like
like the video must have to like
okay so how do you say hit the like
button um
all right we did it how do you say
subscribe but piso is in the canal
that's too long but but piso it is what
but piso it is pizzerias
oh man oh we got the cameras all right
what is it i'm going to give it on a
shot here okay what is it
what pizza it is
[Music]
i don't know what is it what pizza it is
what it's it's nice
this is why you should say it again
i don't know why my plans are confusing
you can take pod pot
no you can't do this
that's okay good enough good enough guys
so we're good all right so with that
said you guys thank you so much for
watching i really appreciate it thank
you so much for
thank you joining us on the iced coffee
hour and i'll link to all of your
information in the description i'll
start a tick tock
uh tomorrow of course and uh yeah guys
make sure to subscribe
uh
get your two free stocks down below in
the description for weeble if you
haven't done that
whoever's watching this who hasn't done
that yet i've said it a million just now
is your chance to do it
and um yeah we're good yeah thanks guys
thank you
sometimes it's this weird behind the
scenes stuff